most of the time people tend to think
confidence is important because it helps
us with success and that is certainly
true we've certainly seen that
confidence is is critical for success I
think though one of the most profound
things we learned in our research for
this book is that confidence is a
wonderful thing for all of our lives not
just our professional lives one one of
the most interesting women we talked to
as a Buddhist scholar Sharon Salzberg
and she described confidence to us as a
kind of energy it's an ability to move
toward things wholeheartedly to move
toward challenges wholeheartedly without
holding back and that that stuck with me
and I think it first of all because I
thought do I ever do that do I ever move
toward anything wholeheartedly without
holding back and and how wonderful that
sounds in all parts of your life the
ability to be able to just take that
risk and jump into things and benefit
from what it feels like to just leave
your comfort zone and do something and
learn is I think that's incredibly
important for women but for most women
our confidence is not calibrated in the
right way we consistently underestimate
what we're capable of and that leads to
to some consequences that you can
imagine and are obvious but it leads to
just missed opportunities in many cases
that we can't even imagine because we
are holding back and because we're we
tend to say I'm not ready for this I'm
not ready to turn in that assignment
that papers not ready I'm not qualified
for this where it's it's just it's kind
of mind-boggling when you think about
the compounded missed opportunities over
the course of a lifetime if you really
don't get your confidence in working
order from the research we've seen what
women need to do is act more and if we
can start to get into our system that in
general every time we're looking at a
situation and especially I'll say a
situation that involves us and our
careers we need to be biased in favor of
acting instead of holding back that's
going to be easy because we're naturally
biased in favor of holding back it's
where our confidence barometer is stuck
this way and and what we really want to
do is just inch it that way so that we
say to ourselves I can do that I am
capable of doing that each time you act
you are building more confidence so
you're building and replenishing your
store of confidence for the next
challenge when you're taking action
whether you succeed or fail right
because you're having these experiences
that are are necessary some failures
necessary and then the ability to
recover from failures necessary but we
never never I learned the ability to
have grit and determination unless we're
recovering from failure so really when
when in doubt act